one answer is that when I was fifteen I
used to like to play pool snooker and
one night I came back really late and my
mother was really upset and worried I
was in South Africa and it wasn't that
safe and she said if you have so much
time to go and play with your friends
you should work harder at school so she
made me skip two years of school and go
to university two years earlier but I
was I had an uncle an aunt who was
scientists and leaning and it was also a
television program on the television in
England in 1964 it was given by a very
famous British Malaya laureate John
Kendrew who got the Nobel Prize in 62
and this was a television program called
the threat of life and it really had a
big influence I remember in South Africa
there'd be no television so for me too
the vision was really a big deal and the
television that I had was probably a
really expensive black-and-white
television about this big if it was
black and yellow and on the BBC then
they had this program the thrill of life
as well as the Winter Olympics of 64 and
I think I liked the thrill of life more
so that sort of made me into that area
so it was a lot of different kind of
lucky things happening I'm very pleased
even without the Nobel Prize I'm very
pleased to be a scientist it's a great
career